i i mean i i'm a person who does her
homework
a lot you already know my teachers out
there but
it's just too much
hello my name is dylan chudzik i'm 18
years old i'm a high school senior
hi my name is rachel i am 18 years old
i'm a senior at union high school and
today we're going to react to some
tickets
my teacher mr ferroni actually is a
pretty famous tick-tocker
all my free time like 90 of the time i'm
on tick-tock i'm not usually on the
teacher's side
because i don't want to find my teacher
who has a tick-tock
my students never complete all their
homework i don't know what to do
why are you having so much homework why
are you overloading these kids with
homework
let them rest when they get home don't
you want to take a nap i'm sure they do
too
for real yeah i have some teachers that
find so much homework
do they realize like we have like a life
outside of school as a senior
senioritis is a real disease already
accepted into college why do you guys
give me more homework we have jobs i've
got sports
there's other stuff in our life that we
want to do it's just
too much i don't know why you're signing
homework we do in class anyways
i i'll study i promise i can get at the
beginning of the year
you know you still have to build credit
and stuff for college
but by the end of the year like you know
now we're in april may
just just why even give us homework he's
like oh my homework's not that hard yeah
it's not that hard but i have 10 other
classes
we're staying home anyway like it's
already homework even though it's
we're at school technically hey why were
you absent yesterday
oh i'm so sorry for your loss
uh that's really funny i don't know how
to comment on that one
i've definitely had that excuse where i
was like i'm sick but i'm really not
i just want to sleep in right now with
like virtual learning i can't really
fake being sick or i can't really fake
being anywhere because they know i'm at
home
i mean you go to funerals all the time
sometimes for people you don't know and
at least the teacher took it well she
wasn't
mad or anything i'm sure she hears stuff
like that all the time
good morning students welcome to another
day of online class
uh so today we're gonna get back into
chapter six does that make any questions
about bimetallism or western expansion
oh my gosh
that's my teacher mr ferroni that's my
teacher mr ferroni
i promise you he does not dress like
that that's not even the right room he's
in he's
lying when he makes these tick tocks
it's really funny like when he tries to
make tick tocks in class and he wants
you to participate in it and he was like
i'll be like okay that was good but
he'll be lying to you because he knows
it wasn't good but i promise you mr
froney
is never wearing shorts and he's never
wearing a suit jacket
but he's always happy to teach us and
i'm glad to have him as a teacher i
remember
one time in class he was testing to see
who was like paying attention
he would turn off his camera be like my
connection's not working and he turned
it on
and he has a completely different shirt
on it ended up being like he changed his
cert
like 11 times and he was like nobody
notice it i'm paying attention to the
lesson not what you're wearing
all right guys that's it for today just
make sure you complete your assignment
it's so great to see you guys have a
great day and i'll see you soon
no this one was kind of sad yeah i
started to notice like there was one
time i stayed behind
just to try to talk to my teacher about
something
and as like all the cameras are going
off i think
that teacher thought i left so like i
just saw the teacher like
like okay i'm done i had to like make
myself okay i'm still
here i'm really sorry and he's like oh
no no no no that's fine i'm
okay but i think i feel you i think i
feel the teachers
i know mr ferroni is being truthfully
honest because
i've seen the days when his chromebook's
acting up and stuff and he's just like
so
upset and so angry and my other teachers
too like
they're not getting what they signed up
for to be a teacher you know people's
got to think of the teachers too i mean
if you think about it this is
this is their life i've had them in
class in person and they just have so
much more energy
and so much more like bedazzle and it's
just like you can't convey that over the
screen the same way
yo mr ferroni do i know you
junior you're student for the last
hundred days honestly doesn't ring a
bell
okay how about now
oh my god junior what's up all right
that's what i mean when mr froney's
always making us do tick tocks
i guarantee you that took them 30
minutes to make i went
to hybrid school and half of my teachers
didn't know who i was
you know why i don't blame them because
i'm not really good with names myself
i have terrible eyesight i'm gonna pause
it so i can read it
i love music yeah
i mean i yeah that's crazy
it's like when you're a kid and you see
your teacher at the grocery store
it's like changes your whole view on
life
as a student if i go to my teacher i'll
just be like i will never see you
other than who you are in front of me if
you tell me you like the same music as
me like cool but also
that's weird so i'm going to give one of
these out every class in case
you're talking too much it's only fair
all right so i'll give it out and you
give it to me anytime you think i'm
talking too much we'll start with junior
so here you go get as many time i'm
talking too much all right
are you serious this is actually the
tick tock same tick tock idea that
he made me film and i never sent him and
i'm still sitting on it
god i shouldn't be saying this they're
gonna watch this like sometimes
you know if my teachers are teaching a
lesson and i already know the lesson or
i just don't feel like paying attention
i will mute them i'll i'll put the
computer on mute
and it's a little scary because what if
they call your name in real life it's
harder to mute someone
the old-fashioned way is just falling
asleep i i've seen the button in the
classroom i've seen it on the table and
i'm very tempted to take it
that button on zoom oh my that end
button
or like leave buttons so tempting
sometimes i like
i like hover around it in class like i'm
like like i'm gonna touch it but i'm not
gonna touch it
[Music]
i think he's told us this before
i'm pretty sure america's gonna be at
the bottom
teachers i feel like are super underpaid
some kids spend most of their day with
their teachers and you know if you have
sports and stuff that's
coaches too who are usually also
teachers when we were actually going to
school
like you go to your you go to school and
you're there for like six
eight hours you go home you're home
alone for a little bit your parents get
home late
you're with your teacher more than your
parents sometimes and you know i feel
like they're just
not appreciated enough in society people
don't give them as much
credit as they deserve like i can name
you like a bunch of good teachers i've
had
that have just like changed my life and
made me the person i
am today we love teachers that's the one
thing i really
started appreciating during coven and
virtual and hybrid learning
like teachers um really do so much and
they sacrifice so much and
like they're essentially essential
workers so we should start treating them
like that
i know some teachers who have like
second jobs and it's
it's i'm not gonna you know i'm not
gonna call them sad or anything but like
a lot of teachers put in way more work
than they need to
just to make sure they're the best that
they could be and
it's just sad to see like such a
important job
be so undervalued and so unappreciated
and a lot of teachers most of my
teachers not even just
only for rooney a lot of my teachers
have gotten me through this year
so you know even when you're feeling a
little bummy
you know fix that hair comb your hair a
little bit take off the hoodie
you know get out of bed and like at
least like share your face or answer a
question in class
for like five minutes or just one moment
so that you can tell you teach like i'm
listening
i'm i'm there for you you know if you're
a teacher watching this give tic toc if
you're not on it
you know it's a funny thing it's
wholesome because it just shows like you
know they're down
to try to connect with their students
and show how they really are and
be funny
[Music]
you